hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
I hope you guys are doing well and you
know it's sort of been a while since
I've done these uh daily analysis videos
and you know today I want to talk about
uh the market because you know yesterday
in one of my training sessions a
question came up about
um you know what would you use in terms
of order flow on you know when a number
comes out like non-farm payrolls today
with CPI
um and to be honest you know one big
important numbers come out I I don't
trade those numbers I mean I I don't
think that
um you know you should really be getting
involved if you're a scalper you know a
short-term intraday Trader you know
you're picking basically the most
volatile time of the day to trade and it
doesn't really behoove you to
participate you know in that volatility
in those moves I mean if you're right
yeah you could
um you know hit it out of the park have
a great uh
you know I have a great trading day but
you know if you're wrong you're going to
get stopped out really quick and you
know it's just going to give you some
bad vibes for the rest of the trading
day so you know honestly on non-parent
payroll days I don't even
um I've learned to stay away from the
markets on those days just because you
know yeah you know you can be right and
have a big winner like today for example
today was CPI right CPI came out s p
shot up you know from eight and a half
all the way up to 25 so it's a nice big
move up then it hit the new highs and
then it sold off not down to the lows of
the day but you know near the low did it
make a new low till uh later in the
session
but I mean you know there's the market
gives you plenty of opportunities every
single day uh to trade you know don't
put yourself in this position where if
you're you know taking a trade based off
of you know the Market's reaction to an
important number like CPI non-farm
payrolls
um you can find yourself
stock trapped whatever you want to call
it in a bad position and you're going to
get stopped out hopefully you get
stopped out you know otherwise you know
if you're running you know mental stops
when people like to use Mental stops for
some reason
um it's going to run against you very
far very quickly so you know and and
again you know Market gives you plenty
of opportunities every day just wait to
the the cash session opens up you know 8
30 Chicago time
to really start to get involved and even
once the cash opens you know me
personally I like to give it uh you know
four or five minutes for the market to
sort of settle down and make its
decision on where it wants to go but the
Market's going to give you a lot of
Clues intraday unworked wants to go in
the near term okay and you know today
was a great example you know for example
we cash opened up right and we took out
the almost immediately took out the
highs that we had made when the CPI came
out now at this point there's not really
any strong reason to be looking to get
short up here at these new highs you
know you don't have a Divergence you
don't have a bearish ratio coming up
here
um you know if anything you got the
bearish value area right here that's
this red value area in the bar but other
than that there's really not a heck of a
whole lot you know that that's really
telling you hey you know what this is a
great short opportunity
um now and we keep going up making new
highs making new highs again even up
here at this level around the the 30
um
three area up here again there's no
strong reason that's you know saying hey
you know what maybe you can get short up
here finally get up to these new highs
up here at about nine o'clock okay then
you start coming off a bit but notice
right this high at nine o'clock yeah you
got the positive Delta going into the
highs but then look what happens for
basically the next you know almost uh
almost 10 minutes after that from you
know this is 903 all the way up to 9 15.
it's mostly negative Delta you've got
one bar here with positive Delta 591 you
got one bar here with Delta of zero
okay zero I mean you know it could have
been plus one you know I don't sit here
and go oh my gosh it's on zero that must
mean something no it's this is a minute
page chart and it's just coincidence
that it closed you know right on the
minute at at zero it could have been
minus three or or plus two or something
like that but anyway it's it's still
it's kind of weak but you know overall
from you hit that high up here
it's all negative Delta for the most
part except this one bar in the high
that you hit earlier here yeah you've
got some negative Delta building over
three minutes it's actually getting a
little stronger 155 minus 406 minus 730
then it comes right back with again a
strong positive Delta now
you know this is you know sort of a
increasing Delta right which normally is
is bearish
but again then the next bar goes inside
of the last candle right that's not a
good sign anytime you go inside of a bar
you're looking to get long or short of
um and it goes inside that's not a good
sign right Market is is hasn't made up
its mind yet if it's really going to go
if this if this bar here at 8 45 started
trading uh below the low of the bar date
44.
um you know I'd be a little bit more
interested in getting short but the fact
that it's just sort of hanging around
inside is not a good sign okay and then
the market went up you got these three
bars here
positive Delta positive Delta a negative
and a negative Delta okay it's just two
bars with negative Delta
you know you got a bar here with Nick
and felta but once you hit this new high
up here now you're starting to see the
aggressive sellers coming in right and
being sustained over you know over
basically a 10 minute period okay then
you're starting to see some bearish
things as well in the order flow okay
what bearish things are you seeing well
you got the bearish Prominent Point of
control up here you got the bearish
value area right that's not being tested
until about four minutes later another
bearish value area you are starting to
get you know sort of alternating
positive and negative Delta bars coming
in here
then you get this big bar down here okay
sort of matches this big green bar up
this one you got strong negative Delta
which again you know the previous bar
you just had positive Delta of 600. the
fact that it's starting to you know the
bar itself is starting to elay elongate
you know is a nice sign you know this
bar here again is similar on the bullish
side but a very small Deltas this is
zero here it's very strong directional
Delta but what's more interesting in
this bar let me just uh expand it up
here for you a little bit what do you
see in this bar right you're starting to
see
um you know some kind of thin prints in
here is at this level of 39 and three
quarters one contract trade so this
Market is moving pretty quick in a
direction in this case the direction is
down
um point of control is you know near the
bottom next bar you got a bearish
Prominent Point of control you got the
value area as well that's being
abandoned it's not being tested in the
next couple of bars sells off a little
bit comes right back up and the same
thing you're starting to see in here
bearish Prominent Point of control
another bearish Prominent Point of
control right you do have a bullish
permanent point of control here at this
swing low and it rallies up to a kind of
a swing high up here at 45 40.
okay then it's just sort of going
sideways but again look at this from
this high overall what is the Delta
telling you it's mostly negative okay
and even if you're looking at say the
cumulative Delta right this is the high
bar right over here cumulative Delta
here was 24 000.
now we're all the way here that was what
904 903 904 933 33 minutes later came
with the Deltas at seventeen thousand so
it's dropped
um you know about seven thousand you
know six and a half thousand contracts
in terms of cumulative Delta so you know
cumulative Delta is going down we're at
the high of the day right if you're at
the high of the day
two things three things are going to
happen right one you're going to keep
going higher two you're going to reverse
and sell off or three you're sort of
gonna go sideways right but now as we
are basically going sideways we do have
a lot of aggressive selling coming in
right even just looking at each
individual bar it's mostly negative
Deltas you do have some positive Deltas
mixed in here but overall it's negative
Delta okay and then we sort of work our
way out remember what I was talking
about the lack of volume here the one
contract that traded okay then you get
to this bar over here bearish evaluary
right that's why it's darker red okay
but more importantly in this bar you're
starting to see that lack of volume also
take place the one contract here
okay 54 against one so it says autonomy
right I mean I know a lot of
um you know order flow gurus out there
always talk about seeing where there's
big volume and trading around that big
volume well you also have to look at the
areas where there's lack of volume
because lack of volume shows lack of
participation or you know sort of the
result of lack of participation is a
market that's moving quickly Traders
haven't had a chance to react
to the market as the Market's moving so
this is you know we talk about term
footprint right this is the footprint of
a market that's moving quickly okay
now let me just uh
scroll this over so you know I'm
starting to see signs here
here with this one right and then this
bar comes in you got a four you got a
zero in here right so at this point I
know that the market is already starting
to be heavy towards the sellers right
because the Delta is obviously most bars
are strong negative Delta right even
here you got minus 900 here minus 1900
I'm starting to see the momentum come in
here the value area is bearish you got
this Gap in value here as well this
Bar's got one two three four five
selling imbalances in it as well so
obviously I'm not looking for expecting
this Market
to start trading higher if anything I'm
looking for it to start trading lower
right and you can see once it sort of
hit that Tipping Point in here where the
big Crush of sellers came in because
this Delta is minus 1900 okay prior to
that the biggest negative Delta was you
know minus 1600 here
this is coming in as we're breaking out
uh you know again this the swing low
here
we had broken out
excuse me but then we just sort of went
sideways now we got a little bit more of
a clean break here with the longer bars
and then that was it the rug just got
pulled out of this market and we
immediately sold off you know from this
29-ish area you know like 29 to 30 all
the way down quickly down
um you know below 19 that's 10 points
um even got down here to what the lowest
uh 45-14 obviously we sold off right now
um we're back up to 4 500 but uh we got
as low as uh 73 and a half
um during the session so
again you know sort of to recap
you know on days where you know there's
going to be volatility in the market as
a result of a big number like CPI which
was today not Farm payrolls last week
no one's putting a gun to your head so
you have to trade that number let the
market settle down
and then start training because you're
going to have plenty of opportunities
during the trading day where things are
very clear okay I mean like I don't say
crystal clear but you know clear enough
that you can make a pretty good uh trade
right because even if you're trading up
in here right just noticing that you
went from this bar here to 10 minutes
later
um you know basically all negative Delta
you can already be thinking this high is
going to be holding and you're going to
be looking for some signs in the order
flow to get short off of right I mean
not every
um
high is going to be taken out and made
new highs also going to be looking for
those potential reversals and it's not
just about trading around the big
volumes you also got to be looking for
those areas of
lack of volumes lack of volume means
lack of participation just really
quickly you know for example Platinum
right because um there's a Trader
yesterday who was asking me about
platinum in the
um in the weekly training and uh there
was a big volume that went through here
194 there's a big order about 250
contracts got bought up from basically
you know 907 and a half all the way up
to
um you know almost 909 and a half you
can see here the 194 that's what was
left over basically this order came in
and swept everything
and you know if you're a dome Trader or
heat map Traders oh my gosh there's a
big volume here I got to buy and get
long well the Market's sold off a little
bit it retraced that whole move down
before it went up and made new highs
okay so just because you have big volume
right I know a lot of people see big and
big order coming into the market they
like to jump in front well
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
this was just a big order going through
the market
right I mean obviously maybe people were
bullish but nevertheless I mean the
market did go up but if you're buying it
here right and you're a dome Trader you
know you're not using wide stops you
know a two dollar stop here
right you're using you know a 50 Cent
stop you know five ticks or something
I mean eventually the market did reverse
and go back up but don't just get lured
into thinking that you know order flow
is just about looking at big numbers you
also got a you know in more liquid
markets like minis you got to be paying
attention to where there's lack of heavy
volume right because that is also
important all right anyone I'm sorry all
right anyone sorry
um
I'm gonna end that video here for today
you know it's been a while I'm a little
bit out of practice of doing these you
know daily live
recordings for you but I'm hoping to
start uh getting back on my schedule and
get them out for you you know if you
haven't had a chance yet be sure to
check out my other video on the order
flows Trader for go charting all right
it's a new platform it's a web-based
platform as opposed to you know if
you're using the ninjatrader platform
you're sort of tied down to your desk
and uh you know it just gives you an
another way to follow the market on you
know I use a Samsung fold phone so the
screen is you know a bit bigger but uh
you know it's it gives you another uh
way to watch the market when you're on
the move so all right everyone thanks
and I'll see you guys on the next video
bye bye